こんにちははじめ社長ですドラクエクリア
するまでトランス止まりません
ラームのことだと思った方いらっしゃると
思います常に発明されましたドラゴン
クエストってボーグナインなんですけれど
もせっかくならプレイしたいんですけれど
もう今回プレイする場所はこちらです
いやもうすごいてああ
うスロ姿だとまだわからないと思う
ちょっと横から見てみましょうか
[音楽]
me
これ俺がドラクエするためだけに作られた
トラックです本会に五湖の中で俺とだけ
プレイしたいと思いますゲームできると
なく見たことないんですこれくすごいん
ですよ星100がーから見ると見てけどね
これスライムですよこの企画のために作っ
てもらったんですこれちょっと何か見て
いきましょうか小澤司正
ふわぁこれが今回僕がプレーする部屋です
部屋でトラックスた上で今回の曲説明し
ますドラクエ10屋内をクリアすると
折れることができますそれまでこの
トラック
えいえんに足り続けます晒し者ですよもう
ただ普通に良い人見ているわけだけどやっ
てるところでクリアするまで走り続けるん
ですけれどもどこまでくればいいかという
と元建ての全館キーんでも5つ集めると
いうところがあるんですけれどもそこが
結構ゲームとシャキリがいいらしいので
teamm の5つだといえばで
これはこのトラックをおりませんつにどれ
くらいかかるか僕よくわかってないよね5
を異例かもわかりませんグーッと張って
ゲーム性とみられるようですね
結構回公開じゃないですよ
動物にゃ安全の財務でシートベルトをぞ
ミスがありますかちょっとこの形で車検
通っているらしいさあ今ご覧ください
[音楽]
木箱ですって今の絶乾素朴なデザインに
なっていると思うんですけれどもここから
さらにデザインがすごいかっこよくという
かもうドラッグ一緒になるらしいのでだけ
勝になってから実際に行く8鯖で折れませ
んやろうと思いますでは東舌までお楽しみ
に
はいというわけでございましたーーー
前見た時はまだ木箱だった油揚するような
空柄末に完成したということでさっそく見
に行きたいと思いますですがドラクエ好き
ですか6うっうっすよどれが一番好き
5と8でございますばかやろ全部って言う
んだよ全部ですねパターン3はウォークが
本スターズ蹴ったことありませんで全部
ただその中でも10のオンラインは別やっ
てたっていうあのステイ form 2気
が狂ったように展やってたんだよそれが
オフラインということで割とストーリーと
か知ってる気がする
ん
[音楽]
ちょっと待ってくださいん
公開処刑やねって動いなんか前回見たとき
ほぼ木箱だったんですけどすごいなニコの
ドラクエの世界観ずっと入ってみると思い
ます
武芸
動いてるめっちゃかわいいメタルスライム
だ
ますけどちゃうんね
いやでもハゲる下手とか好きですね
ちょっと債務経度がするんだけどその吐露
してるあの感じが好き
もう固定は真似されたこれあずかしいでを
毛利許さっていうことで消去
実質もうここまでして頂けたのであれば
もう堂々と行くしかないでしょ
ドン引きしトリオっていうわけで守る出発
するのでちょっと心の準備ができておき
ます聞いた話によると俺書をクリアする
ところをなんとなくず時間金かかるって
言われてよろしくて10時間以上に追わ
れれば待つそこそここれはいけるんじゃ
ないかゲームがちょっとねぇ
スピードも急げつつ遅くならないうちと
頑張りたいと思いますはいというわけで
ドラッグエティンクリアするまでログから
降りれませんいよいよスタートです切って
いきますマジで一人ですからこれこれこの
車はなんか一人でずっと俺誰のもの
だーに上というか全くわからん
ルータだけですから大規模サロンゲストて
目覚めし五つの種族オンライン
いよいよ
スターズ ar
10時からスタートということでこれが
始まりましたんああそれをうしろめて進ん
だまずはキャラ設定ですねこれからあなた
シーンのキャラとあなたともでください
兄弟に彼らの2人のキャラ乗っていますが
これ台としばらく一緒に仲良くするからね
どうしよっかなー
やっぱりこんなのば時間と手間じゃない前
にここでも
方はん
まあカッコいいこれでしょ
出前取った疾病ずかけちゃってる
[音楽]
コンピューターこれでいきますみなさん僕
がこの顔で妹がどこでよしきたぞいよいよ
進めると
始まった
[音楽]
おいすごい
すごいなになってきてるなぁ
いいでしょいいねぇ僕ドラッグへていっか
行ったことあるんですよオンラインで行っ
たことあるんですけども今回のオフライン
ではドローンベストテンの世界を多く
ラインで楽しむことができて僕ない間取り
図れるトム追加されて欲しいけど進めて
いきますね誰かが行くと感じていて
[音楽]
やばい早速ば囲碁ラボドラッグへの大事な
ポイントは村人の話をしっかり聞かないと
マジで探さずに時間かかるてちょっと集中
しながらおります全然街の景色見れてない
[音楽]
ん
ああこう麻布十番店ですねじゃあ朝っぱら
からん
だけヤバいちょっと外が気になって進ま
ないぞこれ
そういう
六本木ん
あー集中しないとヤバイ
[音楽]
はいと上でちょっと進んだバトルができ
ました設定食べてみるもう
もうはいだけで今回のドラクエバトラー
もうお馴染みのターン制のコマンド
パターンとなっておりまぁそんな形写真の
ドラッグへのパターンシステムを採用して
いるので誰でも簡単に楽しめると思います
今どこマンだけちゃったからだけなので
すごい簡単です小吹ないかい
[音楽]
花済みですね流気功やたりできますなぁ
セミナー原宿とこないから新鮮だな
5種してじゃあ
[音楽]
ん
これ
あっはぁ
次された
[音楽]
恥ずかしい
すごいたくさんの人が応援してくれてる
みたい
俺がいらっしゃるああああああ
母皆さんごらんください衝撃ですスタート
1時間で主人公の村が全滅します
やばいよね怖いよでいきなりこんなの
ドラクエ10の最初結構強いんですよ実は
これも住んじゃってません
立っ
光が俺の中に入りました
あとことでちょっと愛知上げて see
この村はゲイ末までに使ってる消滅しって
全員死んでしまいますここから実は
ドラゴンクエストて始まるんですよアイ
テープで一時間経過しました今井ちょっと
車止めて中にいます
ん
[音楽]
数トレイル終わりますようやくここから僕
親族選べ旅が始まるのでスタートれて断っ
たんでって月 emm ここを手に入れ
たらクリアなまでここからがんばってるで
ブラーゲとかしていきたいとおもいますよ
しっと雪でさっそくやっていきましょう
さあその姿になろうかなぁこれが
ですか
[音楽]
通り者取れちゃう
必ずに降り本絵本のような色彩の街でた
またを求めて生きることと入らせ付いたら
体が持たし強いば力呼吸をタオル晴れ持つ
彼らは戦いよりモードを作り出すほどより
ためさを見出すことに情熱を傾け
可愛いフィギュアショップ事故でいきます
まあかわいい水れるんでしょ
クリもかわいいなぁ
髪型も選べるんだ
[音楽]
ブーブー
はっはっは
この弊社みたこの小屋はここからが真のん
follow クエット店のスタート
レース
[音楽]
俺の作戦としては無理にポストが突破
しようとして負けた時またやりナース時間
がもったいないのでなるべくレベル上げし
ていきますいくぞ
判明
強そうな敵がありません飯行こうねー
[音楽]
勝てるかな
ちょっと強そうなんだけどん
[音楽]
戦う相手を間違えたよちくしょう
調子に乗ったが
っていうけど今ちょっと車の半径で1回
停車してちょっと休憩です例えば車停め
トラックは地攻めておくのでどんどん攻め
たいと思いますこれがクリアすればでこの
車を出ることはないというで休憩以外は
で短時間ですあーなんでしたあーーやつの
広場です俺ないからちょっと食べ中であり
ますね
[音楽]
ん
女ビル中になりまし
た weezer 車が立ってる間に集中
してるら行経験値の低い無駄な戦闘を避け
ながら進めていきましょうそれが多分
クリア最速への近道な気がする
[音楽]
はい距離で3時間経過しましたネットで
ベルギーば13で結構レベル上げながら
普通なんでっているのもここからようやく
キーエンブレムを探す旅にようやく出発
できそうです準備は整いましたガンガン
進めていこうと思います
[音楽]
てだけだろ
あ辛いファンが服着たりするべきエーッと
張り合う大きさ
ふぇすたみなさんフォース車の準備をでき
たので出発で打っていきます
チョッキメラ
ここら人は結構
明治かー
まってまってつよいぞ大丈夫か
おい
大丈夫かこれ
やばいやばいやばいやばい
それじゃーんっ
わー
[音楽]
ぱっくわー
増資乗った
バイトに3時間経過しました
レベルが出る17結構来ましたね好きでも
結構増えてきて攻撃力が上がりましたら
tml まで1個手に入れてないん
ちょっと頑張ります
ソースとリースするよかな
ban ん
戦闘勝利回数が100回超えました結構
積極的に先頭もらってるんでレベルも結構
高いはずなんですけどやっぱ無理すると
負けますねー
me
すごい秋葉原ですめっちゃ人がいますね
秋葉原のど真ん中で没前です
いよいよじゃないかこれ
多分
[音楽]
マネー
なんでだボスが強くて勝てないぞ結構
やらかしたが今やっと1回防具所へ行き
ますねこれは笑えないの
[音楽]
渦が経過しましたーー
まずいぞ
まずボス戦で負けます結構大損害ですね
負けると2 f したところからそうです
オートセーブしたところからをできるん
ですけど結構前に戻された
オレはー
心折れかけてます次負けたら健康ないんだ
よこの種族のさず通り全然中まくりたく
ないでしょそっか中版増えてくのテーマ
からずっと1人なんだよ4時間かちょっと
疲れてきたな景色は3つちょっと頑張り
ますね
よしろーすぺ10 f 11 f くれ
たちがを取り戻せ
よっしゃー
どうしました
よかったーっ
使用しオスちょっとススメだぞ
[音楽]
連絡なった
クロバット型近代15
プレザいたしましょう
4試合で名仕上がりやはでいい
キタキタキターはい行きましたというわけ
でやっと城を清める1個目ゲットしまし
たーー
4時間半ぐらいですね4時間半の予約1個
です
これ大丈夫か本当に明日の朝になっちまう
よちょっとここからスピードを上げて
頑張りたいと思います
[音楽]
吸わずレンズを月なっ使ってこれがオン
ライン立てるとき一番よく使ったら街です
ここが
ん
わかる数パターン
とても好きな混ぜた僕は
ですよ
[音楽]
ear
うん
うまー
すぐ休みへな人がとてもたくさんの人に
見守られながら
防戦で多分
頑張るよ3階
+てやるニャー
[音楽]
まずいまずいまずいません
よっしゃ
4少女に恋ゲットデー
[音楽]
お時間半くらいですね文字カーン様
よろしくターゲットです
いいペースだそしてここで若干マンの増え
たっぽいで石油さ
気に食べが楽になりそうねゴシッカ月で3
つで晒すいこうと思います
ていた
さあだいぶ日が暮れてきたのでちょっとね
もう一日は終わっちゃいそうだなっていう
焦りも感じつつ中の人に
ゲームみられてて恥ずかしいでもちょっと
慣れてきましたねあとはもうひたすら俺は
キーエンブレムを集めるだけです頑張って
いきましょう
だこれ
[音楽]
組紐臍
オペレーションん
待って待って待って強いのっ
およよマテマテマテ
これダメだな
end of love000
待って待ってなんで突然育つよ出てくるの
だったぁー
セーラしたから
いやいや光栄
[音楽]
よしポスター湯山助けるらーハリー
よっしゃぁないじゃあ
ショップ
読めません
は2つたぁ
おっけ6つ目です
それ時エイブルゲットしましたあ時間経過
しましたね
何度か聴い ml 分3つゲットしました
4つ子なんとか仲間ももうこれで多分3人
目から桜
いい感じさせる豊里2つなんとか一月が
変われないまでに終わらせないね作って次
頑張ってきたいと思います
相手が来るのはようやく福引ができるよう
になりました軍医危険が中生やりますもう
ふくひびきを持ち版されてしまうと恥のや
釣りそしてマイコーデ要素でをのオシャレ
ば楽しめます僕も二匹目ちゃってたんです
やります玉10円
はいん
[音楽]
俺らぬ
ねえよっ
をやってい
軽減してゴールのか図2にば歪めたれた
構成もふか草逆神たる生物者やすかねこれ
誰だ工作電気玉使って kh 2倍に知っ
てない軽さをしたいなぁいやーこれ家が
引いたんじゃない割と使っちゃいますか
いつかを使うか撮影だったん
これでなんだ
[音楽]
すぐボールのが2倍
スペシャルな香水
これでたりゲームをたが安くなったここで
釣れるしかないん
[音楽]
ちょっと経験前
娶らせないかって
[音楽]
12位
ええええええ
[音楽]
シャア
おっしゃっしゃしゅ
金融強くねっとれいん
感じ時間目にして
4つ目です
あの1個
器エラー
もう外は真っ暗になっちゃいました
voodoo
ある時策定
[音楽]
モーゼ
分からぬタウン
最後かなこの企画中のラスボスだと思い
ません
やばいやばいというん
まずいん
やばい
[音楽]
おっそりー
よし
[音楽]
ああああああああありました
こことってねー
そう
時間ないく時間経過さところ黒いです
大丈夫だよね触れぐらいですね
お疲れ様です
ああああああ
進んじゃってるじゃんかお疲れ様ですすれ
ばですか正しい cml 極集められまし
た
モンスター
去年時間はもうほぼ9時間ぴったりぐらい
だよね
すごいここからまたちょっといろいろ話が
あるんですけどそれはでか皆さん
水遊んでみてくださいドラゴンクエスト
10目覚めし五つの種族をオフライン発売
中様ぜひ遊んでみてくださいいや続き上げ
てデータ僕の言うとし帰ってもらえない
ですなんだかこのトラックくってさー人に
勝手ながら揃えできることないと思う
なかなかじゃない人で発音死んで初ジャン
フェス時は前者によりも買って遊びたいと
思いますじゃあ
あっ
[音楽]
ハール bl